senior researcher dr victor stafford had
an obsession he was one of the scp
foundation's most brilliant minds but
right now that mind was being twisted by
grief and confusion one of his closest
friends in confidence at the foundation
an anomalous astrophysics expert named
dr elibeth orion had gone missing not
killed not kidnapped truly disappeared
without a trace back when dr orion first
fell off the map dr stafford had led the
charge into the emergency investigation
it should come as a surprise to nobody
that employee turnaround at the scp
foundation is higher than perhaps any
other organization on earth we've made
whole videos about the various ways
unfortunate foundation operatives might
die in the line of duty but few things
are worse than never having the closure
of knowing what actually happened to
your missing friend dr orion had
experienced a tragedy almost a year
before her mysterious disappearance her
husband and young daughter were both
killed in a car accident naturally
rumors spread that perhaps the grief had
just gotten too much for the poor doctor
but dr stafford wouldn't hear a word of
it part of him knew that elibith orion
was still alive out there
somewhere but he needed to discover
exactly what had happened to her this is
what sparked the obsession that would
destroy his respectable foundation
career and perhaps even his mind he'd
step beyond professional boundaries by
accessing a number of deeply personal
documents including personnel files and
site 19 project histories he read
through reams of archival documentation
concerning unexplained disappearances of
foundation personnel including the
disappearance of 05-7 several decades
prior dr stafford's search went on for
20 years still finding very little
except an arcane pattern of connection
between each of those who disappeared
all were foundation employees with three
degrees of separation from one another
to put it very reductively a huge number
of disappearances dr elizabeth orion
included he didn't know what was taking
them or why but he would bet his life on
the belief that there was one force
behind it all and while dr stafford had
no real way of knowing he was indeed
right nearly 20 years prior dr orion
found herself in a strange and
unfamiliar place upon waking a year
before that she lived in a two-story
suburban home but after the deaths of
her husband and child she moved into an
apartment in the city that house just
had too many empty spaces in it for her
but now she was neither in her old home
nor her new apartment she was in a
rustic two-level cottage somewhere in
the countryside naturally dr orion first
tried calling for help but there was no
cell phone signal and no wi-fi after
that she tried fleeing the property on
foot only to encounter its first
anomalous effect upon walking out of one
edge of the property you simply reappear
entering the other the house sat at the
center of a half mile of grassy land
cordoned off with a wholesome picket
fence a lonely swing sat near a tree in
the yard no matter how many times dr
orion tried to run past the confines of
the building's land she would appear
facing the rustic little cottage once
more next she started yelling and
calling for help
nothing only birds and squirrels seemed
to register her cries and they ran away
in fear nothing about the cottage
suggested its location was she still
even in the united states anymore and
the flat distant and uninhabited planes
stretching out beyond her only serve to
confirm exactly what she feared there
would be nobody out there to help her
this would be a terrifying situation for
anyone but thankfully dr orion's
foundation training allowed her to keep
cool under pressure she immediately
switched into research and investigation
mode perhaps there would be some key to
her escape or rescue elsewhere in the
cottage knowledge is power and dr orion
certainly didn't like feeling powerless
the first and second floor of the
cottage felt relatively conventional
furniture knickknacks charming but
slightly peeled wallpaper nothing about
it was overtly anomalous soon however
she detected a strange noise coming from
the attic like the slow chugging of an
old machine upon climbing up there she
found a strange contraption made from
wood and metal sitting in the corner of
the attic with a plaque affixed to the
front it also had several pvc pipes
running out of it and feeding into the
wall off into an unknown location dr
orion approached and studied the plaque
it read please fill this machine once
per day at noon time we cannot arrive
with as much haste if the machine runs
dry we hope you understand and trust
that you will keep your side of the
arrangement now that we have kept ours
thank you how strange she needed to
investigate further down in the basement
she found another more anomalous element
to the house a large clump of strange
unidentifiable vegetation it was largely
a kind of murky green with notes of red
and purple that made it seem almost
otherworldly strangest of all when in
the plant's proximity she heard an odd
static-like noise coming off of it it
also intermittently let off a strange
red pulse it didn't take long for dr
orion to intuit that this pulse was
actually morse code delivering two
distinct messages on a loop the first
was thanks for keeping the plants fed
hit a snag in traffic might take a bit
longer than expected and the second was
please keep this hatch open only in good
weather please keep it closed for rain
snow and the chill of winter thank you
just as the message suggested there was
a hatch in the ceiling up above angled
perfectly to allow daylight to filter
through onto the alien vegetation
whenever it was left open the last
notable thing that dr orion found in the
house was seemingly the least
supernatural of the three and yet the
most anomalous in the traditional sense
of the word it was a closed network scp
foundation computer terminal and a
rather old model at that she managed to
boot it up and gain access with her
login credentials but what she saw
definitely didn't bring her any comfort
she was currently trapped in the middle
of what the victims of this place call
scp-2508
the first and most prescient piece of
news was that this little predicament dr
orion found herself in was a life
sentence only one person would ever be
trapped here at a time and they would
remain here until they died one way or
another all she could do in the meantime
is work to maintain the house and hope
that whoever its owner was would someday
return and give her some respite that's
when she found a final note left by 05-7
it read i was driving home when it
happened it was about a 30-minute
commute through a lot of back roads and
i was terribly drunk it was one of those
xk class scenario averted let's
celebrate occasions so i didn't really
hesitate to down more than my fair share
of wine when i arrived at my front porch
cars skewed so that the front tires dug
into the dirt on my front lawn i
stumbled for the door after a great
amount of fidgeting i managed to get my
key in the lock and finally got the door
open but then when i looked around it
wasn't my house at all it was this place
dumbfounded i went back outside surely i
thought i had accidentally entered
another house in my drunken stupor but
now not even the outside was as expected
the suburban urban environment had
shifted to a countryside my car was
still there sitting on the asphalt road
which was now a dirt road everything was
different and it was never quite the
same that was all 23 years ago no doubt
my position as o5 was replaced long long
ago and here i am having found
startlingly few answers every once in a
while i'll find an old shoe or a
photograph of someone who came before me
and i am reminded how we are all chained
together in oblivious and obligatory
service to this place lately the clouds
keep rolling in and the plants in the
basement are buzzing more than usual i
hear the gurgling of water draining
through the pipes and the walls from
that old dusty machine and sometimes i
try to find where that water goes i
think it goes out beyond the house into
the grassy field in front of the swing
set when i lay on the grass sometimes if
i listen very closely and everything
else is quiet i swear i can hear noises
coming from far below the ground they
sound like some kind of clockwork
mechanism it's gears quietly humming i
don't know what it means and i don't
think i ever will undoubtedly the most
puzzling thing about this place is
really quite a small feature there's a
computer terminal in the study and it
looks like one of the oldest things in
the house it's clearly from the
foundation but it's unsettling to say
the least we would have known about this
if the foundation knew i'm sure but if
that's truly the case then it still
doesn't explain how the anomaly got its
number designation is it arbitrary or is
it actually cataloged in the outside
world i don't think it's possible to
know from here sometimes i feel like i'm
waiting for something or for someone
it's not for someone to save me but it's
as if i'm waiting to meet someone here i
dream of what that meeting might be or
why it might be in the first place but
somewhere deep down i know that i will
almost certainly die here and this long
wait will be passed down to another to
continue waiting with baited breath for
something though what exactly that
something is we can't be sure of maybe
someday i'll learn how the food gets
restocked as she finished the note dr
orion felt a cold wave of dread wash
over her she wasn't just trapped she was
the latest in a long line of trapped
doomed people who'd been confined and
then perished in this lonely little
cottage keeping the place in shape while
someone or something made its long
journey back if this was anything to go
by chances are she wouldn't be the last
one to perish here after decades of
waiting as the months turned into years
and the years turned into decades dr
orion stuck it out she learned some
things about the place things she
assumes she might be able to pass on to
others like the machine in the attic the
one that needs water every day is
somehow tied to both the integrity of
the cottage itself and its occupant if
not properly watered the occupant will
begin to grow sick and eventually start
to die back on the outside dr victor
stafford was finally disciplined for his
extracurricular investigations he was
stripped of all his titles and
clearances for spending all his time
searching into the mystery of dr elibeth
orion the foundation frankly had more
important things to deal with they
thought dr stafford was crazy they had
no idea how deep this mystery went about
how many foundation operatives were
taken or most important of all the fact
that stafford knew who would be taken
next back in
scp-2508 things were different for dr
orion nearly 20 years had passed and she
was in a different stage of her life to
some extent she'd come to terms with her
new reality when she dreamed of her old
life she would often wonder whether
those dreams were her actual life and
her time in the cottage was just a dark
recurring nightmare maybe she'd die here
someday and let another take her place
or maybe
she wouldn't dr orion you see was always
the curious type even if she did die
here she'd never let herself die without
knowing what really happened at this
strange little cottage and even more
importantly what was happening under it
now go check out the horror of body
stealing rain
scp-3300 and you'll never make it to
scp-084 static tower for more
frightening anomalous places you'll
never escape